this is what's been happening in India's
Northeastern State of Manipur it's a
part of the country bordering Myanmar
and is now at the heart of a conflict
between predominantly minority Christian
cookie community and the mostly Hindu
majority mateys that's tearing the state
apart
[Music]
a video showing two cookie women strip
naked paraded and sexually assaulted has
sparked outrage across India it was
filmed in early may but only now emerged
due to the state's ongoing internet
blackout
and after months of Silence about the
violence in the region prime minister
Narendra Modi has spoken out
full of pain filled with anger the
Manipur incident which has come to light
is a shameful incident for any civilized
society I want to assure the citizens
that those guilty will not be spared
what has happened to the daughters of
Manipur can never be forgiven
District look on in shock as they watch
the video which we have chosen not to
show
I felt so sad after watching the video
who does this to other human beings why
did they strip them naked you wouldn't
do this to your enemies
the chief minister of Manipur says
police have one suspect in custody
who have arrested one
man culprit
who are involved in his heinous crime
but cookie protest is an activist aren't
convinced by the chief Minister's
statement we all know the chief minister
he is the one who is instigating all
this crisis in Manipur now why he is
speaking peace peace now
Al Jazeera spoke to another victim of
kidnapping and sexual assault by what
she says was a group of metis men
from us and if you are safe if we bought
that place or if you put fir we will
find you out and kill you
a curfew remains in place in the state
capital of imfull to ease tensions while
the number displaced by the violence
keeps growing might level Al Jazeera